[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA MURPHY: Rebecca comes
to us live from Standby.
Quick show of hands--
who in this room has actually
been to the Standby yet?
It's so--
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
LAURA MURPHY: Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Overwhelming.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Thank you.
LAURA MURPHY: Me too.
Me too.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yay.
LAURA MURPHY: Love it.
It's so good.
It's unbelievable.
Thank you so much for
being a part of sort
of the revitalization that's
happening with all of Detroit
and the eateries as well.
Big, as you can tell--
crowd favorite.
I didn't even realize that many
people had been there already.
But a couple more
cool and interesting
facts about Rebecca.
And then, I promise
I'll stop talking
and let you do more talking.
So she's California native.
I think probably the
most notable thing
we'll talk a lot about
today is that you
were a contestant on the
12th season of "Top Chef."
REBECCA LAMALFA: I was.
LAURA MURPHY: Amazing.
So exciting.
She has moved here to--
recently, this summer sometime?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Yeah, I moved in June.
LAURA MURPHY: In June,
from Chicago, right?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY: So
you were in Chicago.
You were head chef
at the Virgin Hotels.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY: And you came
here with your husband,
who is also working in Detroit
as a chef at The Apparatus
Room--
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY:
--Foundation Hotel.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yes, he's the
chef at the Foundation Hotel.
LAURA MURPHY: Tom is his name?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yup.
LAURA MURPHY: Yup.
And you have a
couple fur babies--
REBECCA LAMALFA: I just
collected another one.
LAURA MURPHY: --from
what I understand?
Oh, you have another one?
Last I heard you had
three fur babies.
Now, you're at four?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I have four.
And I have a very
small apartment
right now, especially when
you have four creatures.
But that happens.
He's used to it now.
He used to get so mad at
me for bringing stuff home.
LAURA MURPHY: So wait, it was
two dogs and a cat before.
What is it now?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Now, I
have three dogs and a cat.
LAURA MURPHY: Wow.
That's--
REBECCA LAMALFA:
It's a good story.
Like, I think it's funny.
LAURA MURPHY: Well,
can we hear it?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Sure.
So we have another
restaurant, or bar,
called The Skip in
the Belt. And we only
serve the Mexican-style
Coke, the small ones
in the glass jars.
And we got completely
slammed one weekend.
We had a big DJ
set, and Adidas had
taken over the whole Beltway.
And so they're
like, Chef, you're
one of the only ones with a car.
Can you please go to Honeybee
and get some more soda?
And I was like, sure.
So I go to Honeybee
at like 8:00 at night.
And a big, giant puppy dog
is running around the roads
like freaked out.
And I was like, oh, he got
out of somebody's yard.
So I pull over.
And these other people
tried to get him.
He ran away from them.
And I was like,
come here, puppy.
He was huge.
Jumped in my car.
He was beat up pretty good.
But it was a Saturday night,
and none of the rescues
could take him.
So I was like, OK,
you're either going
to like fit in this
weekend with the dogs,
or you're going to
try to kill my Doxen.
Because I didn't know if he
was a fight dog or anything.
I was just like, all right.
So I gave him a bath
and fed him and kind of
hung out with him for a little
bit, and he never went away.
LAURA MURPHY: Aww.
He adopted you.
REBECCA LAMALFA: He did.
So now I have a 90-pound baby.
LAURA MURPHY: And what
kind of dog is he?
REBECCA LAMALFA: He is a
lab, Mastiff, Pit bull mix.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, wow.
That's--
REBECCA LAMALFA:
But he is just--
and we should have
named him Stimpy.
Because he's totally sweet but
kind of stupid and like just
happy.
He just wants to
play all the time.
He just has no
idea how big he is.
LAURA MURPHY: What
did you name him?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
His name is Busby.
LAURA MURPHY: Busby.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Which is like
totally not a normal name.
But my husband has been amassing
the Manchester United greatest
hits--
players of all time history
with all of my pets.
So my cat's name is
Giggs after Ryan Giggs.
My American Bulldog's name
is Rooney from Wayne Rooney.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh yeah, sure.
REBECCA LAMALFA: And then, now I
have, Sir Busby, who is their--
I don't know-- he's some
like Hall of Famer manager
something or other.
And I was like, OK, perfect.
LAURA MURPHY: That's so funny.
That's one of our
clients, actually.
Chevrolet sponsors Manchester
United, so we do a lot of work
with them.
That's so interesting.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Their
hugest fan lives downtown.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, can
we tell them that?
We might--
REBECCA LAMALFA: Totally.
He'd be so excited,
like freak out.
LAURA MURPHY: We will.
[LAUGHTER]
Small world.
It's a small world in Detroit.
I think you're probably
realizing that,
that you can't walk down the
street and not know someone,
or someone knows someone
from high school or college.
REBECCA LAMALFA: I went
to brunch the other day.
And I was like,
OK, everybody is--
like, everybody-- all the
five people I know are here.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Well,
let's start there.
So we are going to have a
lot more about "Top Chef"
and your fur babies.
But let's start there.
Let's-- very, very
interesting to us--
and there's some timely
news happening right now.
Because I don't know if
you saw, but Google just
announced a couple
of weeks ago we're
making the move officially
down to Detroit next year.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
I'm excited, yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
we're excited too.
So tell us, having not
been-- being a California
native and not necessarily a
Michigander or Detroit native,
tell us what being a part
of the Detroit rebirth
has been like for you.
REBECCA LAMALFA: I love it.
I have been coming to Detroit
for the past four years.
Actually, what's pretty
funny-- four years ago,
we stayed at The Cadillac,
because my bridal shower
was here.
Because we have-- my husband
has relatives in Michigan.
And so I had never gotten
to meet a bunch of them,
so that was how I
met all of them.
And that was the first
time I'd ever really
been downtown Detroit.
And at that point, it
was a little bit scary.
And it wasn't bad.
Like, I think the guy--
we went and had dinner at Roast.
And we were like, where
can we go over cocktails?
And the guy was like, you
shouldn't leave the hotel.
And I was like, well, OK.
Fine.
He's like, no, it's
really a bad idea.
LAURA MURPHY: And that's
just four years ago.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
And now, I recognized the
church that I drove by,
and it's completely like--
it's right across the street
from Little Caesar's Pizzarena.
And nothing was there.
And now, it's like Woodward
has grown up and all
of these beautiful buildings.
It's completely
unrecognizable from what
it was four years ago.
And right after
the show, I started
doing dinners at Revolver.
And steadily,
every six months, I
have done a dinner at Revolver.
So I've been coming and
kind of watching it grow up.
And I tried to get Tom to
move here like two years ago.
And you guys probably
didn't know this,
but Michigan is
huge horse country.
And I grew up showing horses.
So I know a lot of breeders
and trainers are here.
And I was like,
cool, I can like--
I can still show horses
if we move to Detroit.
LAURA MURPHY: That's funny.
You did an interview
with someone
recently where you said
that a big part of moving
to downtown Detroit meant that
you could stable your horses
or you could have your
horses, which I didn't
think that that would be--
it doesn't seem realistic.
And I live here.
I'm from here.
So where do you stable them?
Tell us a little bit about that.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Not
quite Metamora, but
like up right before--
I always forget where
his family's from--
Port Huron.
There is two of the top Arabian
horse trainers in the US
up there.
So it's literally a
45-minute drive from downtown
if it's not traffic time.
LAURA MURPHY: Did you have
your horses in Chicago?
REBECCA LAMALFA: No.
Most of my horses are in
Arizona and in California.
So I had Western Pleasure
horses and [? Reiners. ?]
And they are with my best--
one of my best friends
down in Scottsdale.
LAURA MURPHY: And are you-- do
you do shows with them as well?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Mm-hmm.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh,
that's so interesting.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
So but up here, there's
a lot of English horses.
And I love English
and riding hunt.
So I'm going to get myself
a half Arabian and--
LAURA MURPHY: Very cool.
REBECCA LAMALFA: --hunt.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, very cool.
Well, that's really interesting.
We do hear that a lot
when we get people--
transplants, as we call
them-- from other cities who
have given up a swanky
life in New York
or given up a lot of property
out west to come to Detroit,
that there are some sort
of creature comforts
that this city does offer
someone of your stature.
And so I think that that's
really interesting that horses
is your passion,
and Detroit seems
to be still a good fit for you.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Yeah, it's great.
You get the best of both worlds.
Like, we can't really
live too far away
from a major
metropolitan area that's
just-- our jobs don't translate
well to that, the kind of food
that both of us do.
So it works out really well
that we can have a property
and have animals.
And I have always had cows
and pigs and horses and all
that stuff.
And now I can actually
do that and afford
to buy a house that isn't
the size of a postage stamp.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
it's a little expensive
down there right now.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, OK, so in
that same theme of Detroit,
let's talk about Standby.
Standby, James Beard
Award nominee right now.
It's typically known
as a bar that leads--
or a restaurant
slash bar that leads
with really well-known strong
alcoholic drinks, bar drinks.
That's kind of how you guys
have your reputation building
right now.
Tell us, as a chef coming
into a restaurant with a bar
with that type of
reputation, how
it's been challenging
for you or how
you've been able to
either complement that
or what you see from a negative
and a positive standpoint?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I thought
it was a great project.
And I came from having
five restaurants
under my hat to having
one that was really
focused, was really nice.
And I could bring the
food to the same level
as the cocktails.
And my job was to get it
there, get us more organized
so we can continue to
work on other projects
and expand the company.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
What are you most proud of
that you've done at Standby?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Just
the consistency, I
think-- consistency
and that we don't
have a disparity between
the food and the cocktails.
Before, we had-- we have
a $20 drink on the menu.
But it's like everything
is a lot snackier.
And that's just-- they just
hadn't found the right fit
of person to kind of do that.
And to me, Standby is a cocktail
bar that has great food.
It's not a restaurant
that has great cocktails.
So that's something that I try
to keep in everybody's mind,
that I'm there to
complement the food
and to help us do other things.
LAURA MURPHY: Yet, you have
quite an extensive background
as a chef.
Let's talk a little
bit about "Top Chef."
So "Top Chef," I think
it's what all of us
know, it's how you
got your chops.
But is there some
other way that--
do you think "Top Chef" kind
of has outshadowed something
else in your life you're
really proud of that got you
to where you are now?
Or would you credit
"Top Chef" for that?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I think I did
"Top Chef" because it was just
an easy point in my life
to be able to do that.
We were really
fortunate to where
my-- the company that I was
working with, Trencherman
and the Heisler Group were--
was like, yes, do it, please.
And I was like,
oh, I don't know.
I'm like, that's not my deal.
I don't really do that stuff.
But I think what I had kind
of done to get there before
was a good lead up to it.
It certainly wasn't my favorite
thing that I've ever done.
But I don't regret it.
I never wanted to
regret doing it.
And they asked me, like they
begged and begged and begged
me do it.
And I was like, all right.
I'm just not a very
good social person.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Well,
you could've fooled us.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Aw, man.
I kept my mouth
quiet a lot, which
is one of the reasons why they
were like, you're very quiet.
I'm like, well, because some
of the things that come out
of my mouth aren't very nice.
[LAUGHTER]
And like, I just like--
LAURA MURPHY: I
feel you, sister.
[LAUGHS]
REBECCA LAMALFA: Well,
you're just like--
you're stuck in a
weird situation.
And I think the most frustrating
thing for me was I was like--
and the same thing with James.
We both agreed on this one.
We were like, good
food takes time.
And that's what they
take away from you.
They take away the two
most important things
about being a really good
chef that really cares
about your food is
time and the ability
to pick your ingredients.
One of the biggest
things about our job
is sourcing the best ingredients
and local ingredients
that we can.
So it's a little bit like--
you never feel like you're
putting your best foot forward
for somebody that you
completely admire.
Like you're cooking for Jacques
Pepin, and you're like, wow,
I just ran through
Whole Foods that were
ravaged like three days ago.
It's a three-day weekend.
We know they didn't
get any fresh orders,
because we know how
everything flows
in and out of these places.
And I'm going to put this in
front of seven million people.
And I'm cooking on a stove in
like an apartment near you.
And this is like, awesome.
Here you go.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
It's just like, ugh.
LAURA MURPHY: But
for the most part,
you were given some really
positive feedback on that show.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Oh yeah.
I had a good time.
I mean, I met so
many amazing people.
It's definitely
like nobody knows
what you go through, except
for like the 15 of you that
are there.
So we're all pretty close.
LAURA MURPHY: Pretty tight.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Which was fun.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, you
met some amazing people.
There's a lot of
celebrity chefs and a lot
of celebrities,
really, in general
that you came across
with on that season.
Who was your favorite?
Who stands out to you
as someone you were most
glad to meet or network with?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I think
I was pretty over it
by the time we had
to meet people.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Would you say
one of the other contestants?
REBECCA LAMALFA: It was really
fun to be in the "Cheers" set
and do-- and meet Norm
and do all that stuff.
And then, he came
to my restaurant
like four months later.
And we weren't allowed
to talk about it,
because we-- it
hadn't aired yet.
And he was like, I love
your chicken wings.
I was like, thanks.
[LAUGHTER]
That was super funny.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh my
gosh, that's awesome.
That's very cool.
Yeah, that was a great one.
REBECCA LAMALFA: That was fun.
LAURA MURPHY: So
post life "Top Chef,"
was there one of the
other contestants
that you stayed in touch with?
I think we know
the answer to this.
You already mentioned
a couple of names,
but someone who stayed in touch
with that you've really felt
you built a network around?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Well, James
and I are really close.
LAURA MURPHY: James, yeah.
REBECCA LAMALFA: May and I
talk pretty much all the time.
Carrie-Ann and I are
still really good friends.
We were roommates.
George and I were really close.
We hung out together a lot
after we got eliminated.
It was really fun
to get eliminated,
because you're
stuck in this house.
And you're like,
wow, I don't have
to do anything besides
entertain myself.
LAURA MURPHY: What would you
do once you got eliminated?
I've always wanted to know this.
When you get eliminated,
then what happens?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I'm probably
gonna get in a ton of trouble
for telling you this.
But I don't really care.
I'm like, what are
going to do to me?
I've got nothing.
They basically rented
out like a Residence Inn,
and we all got
our own apartment.
And you get like--
you get so much money a
week for food and stuff.
So we took over the pool,
and we barbecued every day,
like way too much.
Yeah.
And then we would--
yeah, it was awesome.
We had a great time.
And it was summer.
It was like none of
us have ever been
able to be off-- have this
much time off in our life
and to not have to like run
and check on the restaurant
or do something else.
As a chef, you're
always just on.
So it was really awesome to be
like, wow, this is like what
actual vacation feels like.
LAURA MURPHY: It's like
celebrity chef adult Spring
Break.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Totally.
[INAUDIBLE] we
were like, you guys
should have had
the cameras here.
Like we one time snuck
out and went to karaoke.
And James was a
huge karaoke-aholic.
That was hysterical.
We had a great time.
LAURA MURPHY: How fun.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
We had a great time.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, OK.
So "Top Chef," the
rebirth of Detroit,
you have so many
interesting layers to you.
I don't even know
where to start.
But one of the other
things I do want
to talk about because
you're at Google,
and there's a number of things
that we prioritize here.
Work-life balance
is one of them.
Hearing that you
have your horses here
with you, which affords
you a better life
is awesome, because we
can all relate to that.
But talk to us a little bit
about something else that's
very important here at Google.
And have a group called Women @.
And part of our initiative
behind that is just
to kind of uncover
truths and do a lot
of sort of sharing of
our lives and things
that make being a woman
in a technology field
at a very large corporation
with a big reputation--
it's not always easy.
I cannot imagine almost a
tougher industry than being
a chef, a professional
chef in the industry that
you're in and being
female and leading that.
So talk to us a little bit
about some of the challenges,
or if there's one big
one that stands out
for you and in your
journey as a female chef
amongst what I think is probably
a pretty big boys' club.
REBECCA LAMALFA: It
is a huge boys' club.
I just never put up with it.
And I didn't ever
realize that I wasn't
going to put up with it
until I was at Michael Mina.
And I always just
kind of focused
on doing a really good job.
And if I knew--
I knew I needed to
get better, and I
was looking over at what
other people were doing.
And I just made sure--
I just made sure I worked
harder than everybody else.
But there was a couple
of people that--
you always run across some
guys that don't want you there,
especially-- this is going
to sound really terrible--
but there's a lot
of foreign chefs
that we work with that is
not- that's not a big women
crossover into their workforce.
So they were like, get out.
And you're not conforming to
whatever cultural program is.
And I was like, dude,
if you want to go toe
to toe back here, fine.
LAURA MURPHY: Bring
it on, chef style.
REBECCA LAMALFA: I don't care.
You're not going to get in the
way of me not doing my job.
But I'm also not going to
let you treat me like garbage
or throw my stuff away or--
LAURA MURPHY: Oh,
would they do that?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Oh, yeah.
Kitchen sabotage is huge.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh my god.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Huge.
Yeah.
I need that pot.
[PFFT] Oh yeah, completely.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh,
that's horrific.
I'm sorry.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Oh, not a big deal.
LAURA MURPHY: I
love that you say
that you just-- that you
just won't stand for it.
REBECCA LAMALFA: No.
Dude, like if you touch my shit
again, I'm going to burn you.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like prison rules, man.
Like you get there early,
get all of your stuff.
And if you continue to
try to take my stuff,
I'm going to put a
spoon on the flat top,
and I'm going to
hold it to your hand.
Don't.
[LAUGHTER]
But as soon as you like--
they figure out that you're
not going to put up with it,
the stuff stops.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Wow.
So that's amazing and
actually even more
terrifying than the way I
thought you would describe it.
So good for you.
I love-- again, I just love that
you have the balls to just say,
I'm not going to stand for this.
And I'll sabotage
you right back.
So it's--
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Yeah, I'm also--
LAURA MURPHY:
[INAUDIBLE] belong here.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Like, don't.
LAURA MURPHY: You're
good for this city.
[LAUGHTER]
REBECCA LAMALFA: I'm not
going to put up with that.
LAURA MURPHY: So then,
the next obvious question
is, two chefs in one family--
incredibly difficult. Back to
the work-life balance thing.
But how do you and
Tom make it work?
Because it's nights.
It's weekends.
It's early mornings.
Do you find that that
presents itself a challenge,
or is it easier?
REBECCA LAMALFA: It was
probably a little harder
when we were first together,
because we didn't really
have super control
over our schedules.
But now, we both kind
of make the schedule.
And we both really understand
that if something happens,
if you have something going
on on Sunday, of course
you have to work on Sunday.
That's OK.
But we try to make sure that
we have Sunday or Monday
or both days off a week, so
we actually see each other.
I feel like it makes us
appreciate each other more,
because we are not on
top of each other at all.
Like we leave by 9:30,
10:00 in the morning.
One of us will come
home and walk the dogs
and hang with the
dogs during the day.
And then, we don't
get home until 12:00.
LAURA MURPHY: Wow.
And then repeat.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY:
Rinse, wash, repeat.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Absolutely.
LAURA MURPHY: Who's
the better chef?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
That totally depends.
We do totally different
styles of food.
LAURA MURPHY: Tell
us about that.
REBECCA LAMALFA: So he's like
ultra fine dining all the time.
And I did that for a long time.
And I was just like, I
don't need this in my life.
[LAUGHTER]
I remember a pinnacle moment.
We were actually here two
years ago doing Savor Detroit.
And Tom was paired up
with Luciano from Bacco.
And I was like just because
your restaurant's name
is 16 does not mean
you need 16 garnishes.
Whoa.
I think I'm one of
the only people that
can get away with saying that.
And I was like sometimes--
like, you know,
Chanel says when you
look in the mirror
before you go out the
door, take something off.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Very true.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Applies here.
LAURA MURPHY: But
that's his style.
So your style, then,
is a little bit
more simplistic I would guess.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
And that's kind of how
I take Standby is--
I'm like, well,
what tastes good?
What's going to-- to
me, it doesn't have to--
I don't want to-- it to be more
complicated than it has to be.
To me, kind of less is more.
Let the stuff speak for itself.
LAURA MURPHY: So you
didn't answer us, though.
Who do you think is the better--
the better--
REBECCA LAMALFA: I don't know.
I mean, he's 10
years older than me.
So technically, he would be.
But like, if you ask who
makes dinner every day.
LAURA MURPHY: Is it you?
Actually, that was on
my list of questions.
So what-- what's your
go-to recipe home?
You're not home, really,
ever at the same time.
But if you had to cook something
or you had friends coming over,
what's your go-to?
REBECCA LAMALFA: If we
have friends coming over--
that's a tough one.
It's usually a holiday,
so whatever holiday food.
I totally nerd out
over the holidays.
So I go crazy that way.
And we both love Thanksgiving,
so Thanksgiving becomes
like a giant raucous of stuff.
I'm like, who are
we going to feed?
We have like five friends
between us and every--
LAURA MURPHY: I'll come over.
REBECCA LAMALFA: I was
gonna say, and we have--
and everybody's working.
LAURA MURPHY: I'm
free this year.
[LAUGHTER]
REBECCA LAMALFA: But we
could really simply at home.
Tom loves meatloaf
and pot roast.
So that's basically
what I make at home.
It's completely not
what people think.
LAURA MURPHY: So he's
more of like a fluffy,
luxurious 16-course
meal or 16 sort of--
[INAUDIBLE] big.
But he likes your-- he likes
just good home cooked--
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
He cooks breakfast
every Sunday morning.
And that's the most
cooking he does at home.
And then, I usually do
dinner and stuff like that.
But yeah, we're
totally simple at home.
We cook like everybody else.
LAURA MURPHY: Do you use
any social media channels
or YouTube, maybe, for any kind
of recipe guidance or cooking?
REBECCA LAMALFA: No.
My Instagram is full
of dog pictures,
which [INAUDIBLE] totally
disappointing for some people.
But yeah, I have a Doxen,
and I think he's funny.
So I post pictures
about him all the time.
But no, generally YouTube,
I watch makeup tutorials
and get out of chef world.
LAURA MURPHY: OK.
So you actually are
not using YouTube
to sort of perfect
your culinary craft.
You're using it more for
your personal [INAUDIBLE]
REBECCA LAMALFA: I do point
my sous chefs and stuff
to a channel called ChefSteps.
And they are awesome.
So if you're like, OK,
I suck at boiling eggs,
they will show
you like four ways
to hardboil and peel an egg.
And they also do a lot
of molecular gastronomy.
And they do some
really high-end things.
But they have some
really fun stuff.
Like if you're like,
OK, I want to figure out
how to make hollandaise sauce
and put it in an iSi gun
and blow it up, like, OK, cool.
There's the video.
LAURA MURPHY: Very cool.
Well then, who is your-- you
said you use makeup tutorials.
Who's your favorite
YouTube creator for that?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Oh my god, I
have like a million of those.
I like to watch them all.
LAURA MURPHY: And no one stands
out more than the others?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I watch
Bailey Sarian a lot.
LAURA MURPHY: Bailey.
Michelle Phan maybe?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I don't
watch Michelle Phan very--
I used to.
But Jaclyn Hill does a good job.
And a couple of girls over
in the UK I really like.
It's a little bit more
of a natural look.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Yeah.
REBECCA LAMALFA: There's a lot
of makeup going on these days.
And I'm like, I don't
have time for that.
I also don't want to feel like--
we sweat a lot in the kitchen.
And nobody feels good
by like hour ten,
and you look like you've
jumped out of a swimming pool.
And you're like, wow, I just
went upstairs to the dining
room, and I look like I
have either been crying
or at a Marilyn Manson concert.
[LAUGHTER]
It's not a good
look for anybody.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, you
look beautiful in everything
I've ever seen on TV.
So that's--
REBECCA LAMALFA: One of my best
friends is a makeup artist.
So she always does my--
fixes me before I have
to go on [INAUDIBLE] public.
LAURA MURPHY: Is she in town?
REBECCA LAMALFA: She
travels all of the time.
She is the lead makeup
traveling artist for the UFC.
So she covers up bruises mostly
and makes the girls beautiful.
But yeah, she's the one who's
always like, OK, hold on.
[CLICKS]
LAURA MURPHY: You
mentioned you and Tom,
when you are together--
maybe Mondays or Tuesdays--
you have date nights.
Is there-- outside
of the Foundation
Hotel or Standby-- is there a
favorite hotspot you guys like
to go to in Detroit?
REBECCA LAMALFA: We always
try to go someplace different.
Because there's like everybody--
LAURA MURPHY: So many.
REBECCA LAMALFA: So many
friends have restaurants and so
many places to go,
which is really awesome.
It's kind of nicer to go out
here than it was in Chicago,
because it's just less like--
everybody here has a purpose.
And instead of
like, oh, I decided
I'm gonna open a Chinese
restaurant, that's cool.
Like, mm, all right,
that's now what you do.
So we basically try to hit
all of our friends' places.
And then anything
that's been around
for more than 50 years, like we
totally love restaurants that
have been around
for a million years,
even if they're like funny and
like totally old and nostalgic.
The funnier, the better.
LAURA MURPHY: Mm-hmm,
like Clawson Steak House.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Totally.
I can't wait to go there.
It's totally on our list.
LAURA MURPHY: You haven't there?
REBECCA LAMALFA: No, because
they close on one of the things
that we're always off.
LAURA MURPHY: Aww.
REBECCA LAMALFA: So yeah, like--
LAURA MURPHY: It's
the best place ever.
REBECCA LAMALFA: We
loves places like that,
anything that's kind of funny.
One of our first dates
was at Bucca di Beppo,
because it was funny.
And this is like
the weirdest goal,
but we were like, we want
to go someplace and order
the nicest Chianti on the
menu and have it be one
of those stupid basket ones.
LAURA MURPHY: That's
the place to do it.
REBECCA LAMALFA: And
then, so this is like--
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, Roma Cafe?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Yeah, that was--
well, and-- where were we?
We were in Vegas, so there
wasn't a Roma Cafe there.
And we didn't realize they put
us downstairs in the basement,
because we must have
looked like trouble.
But there was this private
party of deaf people.
So we were like, it is
really quiet in here.
What is going on?
And then, it dawned on us
like halfway through our meal.
And we were like, oh,
they're a private party,
and they stuck us in their room.
And they're all signing.
No wonder there's no
music or anything.
We were [INAUDIBLE]
sitting, like, shh,
something's going on.
LAURA MURPHY: This
was your first date?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah, it
was one of our first dates.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: That'd be
tough, tough to connect
when it's quiet.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
It was hysterical.
We had been-- had plenty
to drink before that.
So yeah, it was--
that was super funny.
LAURA MURPHY: What
about in Detroit?
I said Clawson Steak House.
But what's your favorite old
place, 50-plus years old--
anywhere that you
could name off?
REBECCA LAMALFA: We loved going
to the London Chope House that
has been opened and redone.
That was really, really good.
And it's fun.
And going up to the
cigar bar is really cool.
And so so far, that's been
kind of the number one--
we love to go to Jacoby's
because it's funny.
Sweetwater Tavern we live
across the street from,
so I've had enough for them.
Every day I walk my dogs,
and I have to fight them
for chicken wing bones.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
That's a kind of a nasty
corridor down there sometimes
when there's--
after a Lions game or
St. Andrew's Hall concert
or something.
REBECCA LAMALFA: So
if you can imagine--
my Doxen is feisty.
So I'm trying to like--
and he's growling at me.
He's like, I want
that chicken bone.
[INAUDIBLE] You've
got to let it go.
LAURA MURPHY: We
spend a lot of time
down there with--
some of us have
clients and such around General
Motors and around the ad
agencies.
So we're always looking
for good recommendations.
What do you think is
the best lunch place
around that same area?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Lunch is tough, man.
LAURA MURPHY: Lunch is so
tough, besides the Standby.
Well, Standby doesn't
open until 4:00.
REBECCA LAMALFA: We don't 5:00.
LAURA MURPHY: 5:00, yeah.
REBECCA LAMALFA: So yeah,
we're late-- we do late night.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Desserts till 2:00 AM.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
And we do like-- we do
chicken and dumplings
from 12:00 to 2:00.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh,
I didn't know that.
That's cool.
REBECCA LAMALFA: There's
like nice, hot something
to get at 2:00 AM.
Because there's
really not a lot.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
But lunch?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Go Sy
Thai is really good.
I don't-- like, I like the
salads that they have at Grand
Trunk.
LAURA MURPHY: We do too.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
[INAUDIBLE] Grand Trunk.
LAURA MURPHY: We spend
a lot of time there.
REBECCA LAMALFA: It's one of
the few places that's open.
The Apparatus Room, if you
can get in, has great lunch.
I sit at the bar.
[INAUDIBLE] But
yeah, there's just
not a whole lot of places
to have lunch downtown yet.
We're working on it, but--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
We think that's a big
opportunity, especially
with companies like
Microsoft and hopefully,
Amazon, and obviously,
Google moving down there.
Definitely an
improvement for lunch.
REBECCA LAMALFA: It's
all in the works, man.
All that stuff is coming.
LAURA MURPHY: Are you gonna--
is there anything you want to
reveal today here at Google
in that same vein around--
REBECCA LAMALFA: Not yet.
We just know that we never have
plans that we want to do that.
Like, that's in the--
because there's--
they're literally--
we all go to the Dessert--
Dessert Oasis--
Desert Oasis Coffee--
LAURA MURPHY: Desert
Oasis Coffee, yeah.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
--to have meetings.
And we're like, this would
be great if there was food.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
REBECCA LAMALFA: And
there's only so many times
you can eat at the little
Mexican [INAUDIBLE]
on the corner.
LAURA MURPHY: Mm-hmm.
It is good, though.
REBECCA LAMALFA: It is good.
But when you've had--
I'm like, OK, we've
all had their menu.
And we all are totally lazy.
And we get delivery at
Standby like all the time.
So I'm like, oh my god,
you guys, we have to stop.
There's nothing healthy about
anything that we're doing.
[LAUGHS]
LAURA MURPHY: Do you think
when Google moves down
to Detroit you might come
over and celebrity guest
chef for us one day?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I could.
LAURA MURPHY: Is there a way
we could get you to do that?
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah.
How many people do
you have to serve?
LAURA MURPHY: OK, awesome.
It'll be about, what,
120 at some point,
but 80 maybe at first?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Oh, that's not bad.
LAURA MURPHY: We'll figure
that out afterwards.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah,
I can only do that.
That's easy.
LAURA MURPHY: OK, awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
REBECCA LAMALFA:
That's totally easy.
LAURA MURPHY: Great, so I think
that concludes the interview.
No, just kidding.
REBECCA LAMALFA: OK, perfect.
We got what we wanted.
Leave.
LAURA MURPHY: Right.
So why don't I stop talking?
There's a microphone over here.
Is there anyone with any
questions for Rebecca?
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
maybe expanding a little bit
outside of the Standby.
Are you looking to
just kind of stay
in that sort of
midtown/downtown area?
Or are you looking at any
of the other neighborhoods?
For example, West Village
has some good development
going on there.
So just curious, what
areas are you looking at?
REBECCA LAMALFA: We just bought
a house over in that area,
over in Indian Village.
We're super excited about it.
And there is no room
right now in West Village.
Everything is rented.
So West Village is going to
blow up here really soon with--
I know there's at least three
or four restaurants opening.
My buddy, Anthony Lombardo,
is opening his restaurant.
I can't remember the
name of it right now.
But he actually moved
over to Midtown,
because he couldn't get
in in West Village, which
is-- it's exciting.
LAURA MURPHY: It's a big deal.
REBECCA LAMALFA: There's still
plenty of space downtown.
And I don't mind
staying downtown.
I like it down there.
And I think downtown needs it.
I'm not a super
huge suburb person.
I like to come out
here to go shopping.
But I feel like there's lots
of amazing stuff out here.
And there's a lot of
call for new things.
So we're focusing--
both of us are focusing
all of our energies downtown.
LAURA MURPHY: Thank you.
That's good.
We need that.
You're absolutely right.
If we could just
figure out a way
to get some of that
shopping downtown
and get people to
stay down there.
REBECCA LAMALFA: If we convince
Nordstrom's to move downtown,
that would be great.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: OK, on it.
We had another question here.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that you're out the door
at around 9:30 until 12:00.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
you do in your typical day,
from when you start to finish?
REBECCA LAMALFA: So my day
starts with making sure that
my sous-- my morning
chef has like--
all the orders have
come in, it was all
the stuff I actually ordered,
everybody is on the same page,
that we have on prep projects
with, OK, burger meat is here.
We patty those fresh every day,
making sure that that's done,
fries are blanched by a certain
time so by the time the cooks
come in, they're kind
of out of their way.
And then by that time, my other
two sous chefs have made it in.
And normally at that
point, I have meetings.
And then, I have meetings
in and out of the city.
So I'm kind of out and
around all the time.
And the past couple
of months, we
have opened a cart
out in the alley
that we brought you
guys some snacks from.
But we're just-- some
simple little fun things.
LAURA MURPHY: Biscuits?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Yeah, biscuit cart.
LAURA MURPHY: Biscuits?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
So we-- it was--
I was focusing a lot on like,
OK, we need equipment for that.
We need to get
bids for equipment.
We need to figure out what
we're going to serve it in.
How many people does
Jesse need to run that?
So I spent a lot
of time doing that.
And we are also in the works
of opening another bar down
the way, down at the
end on Library Street.
So that's been another focus.
Because I'm going to do soft
serve ice cream in there.
So I'm [INAUDIBLE]
LAURA MURPHY: Oh yay.
That's exciting.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
That will be fun.
LAURA MURPHY: Have you
announced the name of that,
or is it still in the works?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I think it's
called Deluxe Flux of Deluxe
Luxe or something like that.
LAURA MURPHY: Deluxe Luxe.
REBECCA LAMALFA: But that will
be open sometime in March.
That's going to be really fun.
LAURA MURPHY: You mentioned
meetings outside of the city.
I know you do a lot of
sourcing from local farms.
Is it usually related to that?
REBECCA LAMALFA: So I do that.
I help-- I consult
for a couple of people
that I'm just helping them get
their restaurants up and around
and menus and things like that.
I have a couple of
meetings with people that
want to do private dinners.
And then, every doctor's
appointment in the world
is over out here.
And then anybody-- the one thing
that needs to come downtown
desperately is a grocery store.
LAURA MURPHY:
Nordstrom's and a grocery
store-- a non-- a non-Whole
Foods grocery store.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yeah,
because Whole Foods is tiny.
And it gets picked
over immensely quickly.
So if you need like
Ziploc bags, you're hosed.
And CVS closes really, really--
and that gets picked over
really quickly.
So if you're like, OK, I need
to get actual staples of life,
you have to drive
out to Eight Mile.
LAURA MURPHY: You mean City
Market doesn't have everything
that you need?
[LAUGHS]
REBECCA LAMALFA: Well, it's
also picked over quite quickly.
Those people know us very well.
They love my dogs.
[LAUGHS]
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, that's great.
Well, I don't know if
there's any other questions.
But what I'd love
to have Rebecca do
is talk a little bit about what
she brought for us today, what
you guys are going to enjoy.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yes.
So we just changed the
menu, the dessert menu.
Julie and I love dessert.
So that's Juliette.
That's my sous chef in the back.
Hi.
LAURA MURPHY: Hi, Julie.
REBECCA LAMALFA: So we brought
you what our latest dessert
that we put it on the menu.
It is a sour cream
old-fashioned donut
with dried cranberries, pumpkin
cheesecake, and apple butter.
LAURA MURPHY: Wow.
REBECCA LAMALFA: And we brought
some of the snacks that go out
on the skip cart, which is
some spiced pecans with milk
and dark chocolate rolled
[INAUDIBLE] around it.
LAURA MURPHY: Are there any
local companies or farms
in this-- that go
into this recipes
that you brought today that you
could hype up or tell us about?
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Yes, so Seedling Farm
has been a farm that I use
in Chicago quite a bit.
And Pete was a tech guy
that bought this farm from--
that has been around
for over 100 years.
But I think the
gentleman that owned it,
his family didn't want
to keep it in the--
I don't know, I don't think
he had anybody to leave it to.
So Pete bought it.
And they live in Chicago.
And they drive all the way up
to Grand Haven every weekend
to make sure that this
farm continues to run.
And it has heirloom
pears and like
six different-- no, like 15
different varieties of apples,
ground cherries, cherries, figs.
He has all sorts of fun stuff.
So we get all of our
apples from those guys,
and they ship them-- they truck
them in from across the state.
LAURA MURPHY: That's cool.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
We also buy from--
I think it's called
Grow Detroit.
And it is a company that goes
around and helps little farmers
get their product
to restaurants.
So we have one
place to order from.
And they make sure
that we get to use
some really awesome things.
And some of these guys only
grow one or two things.
But they grow-- like this
guy grows amazing beets.
Or he has really
awesome zucchini.
So we'll buy the flowers
and all that stuff.
But it will come
from one person.
The guy's name is Eton.
It's really fun.
LAURA MURPHY: Aton?
Eton?
Eton.
It's interesting, because
Chicago's not too far away.
So you can kind of share
and stay with the same farm.
Seedlings sounds like
maybe one of the ones
that you did that with.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Yes.
And what was annoying
when we moved
here is a lot of those farmers
on the west end of Michigan,
it's so much easier to go to
Chicago that they're like,
oh, we don't drive to Detroit.
I'm like, well, can you?
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
You're in Michigan, right.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Which is
working out really awesome,
like they are, which is great.
LAURA MURPHY: Has
there been any--
like a Michigan
staple or product
that's changed the
way that you cook,
because you were so surprised
by the cherries or the apples
or something?
REBECCA LAMALFA: I didn't
realize that Michigan had nuts.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh.
I didn't either.
REBECCA LAMALFA: So
in southern Michigan,
there's quite a few pecans and
stuff, which is interesting,
my dad's a nut farmer.
So that was awesome.
But not really-- I mean,
growing up having a ton of stuff
at my disposal I was super--
I'm always super
excited about cheese.
So I'm always finding local,
small, artisanal cheese people.
LAURA MURPHY: There's a
million good ones here.
REBECCA LAMALFA:
I know, I love it.
One of the local farm people
goes around and picks up
cheese from all those places.
So I'm like, I'll be on
a two-week waiting list.
I don't care.
I just want like one or
two of those things that
are available.
LAURA MURPHY: Share with us,
who is the best artisinal cheese
distributor around here.
REBECCA LAMALFA: I can't
remember the name of his farm.
They're right
outside of Ann Arbor.
And they literally
have like 20 goats.
LAURA MURPHY: Wow.
We'll have to figure that one--
REBECCA LAMALFA:
Yeah, I'll find--
I'll figure it out.
But I was super excited
to get their stuff.
But yeah, I ordered it.
And they're like, it's
a two-week pre-order
And I was like, dammit.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll wait.
LAURA MURPHY: Yup.
Good cheese is worth
the wait, for sure.
REBECCA LAMALFA: Absolutely.
I love cheese.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, thank
you so much, Rebecca.
Can we get a big round of
applause for Rebecca coming?
[APPLAUSE]